world-premiere it's been 15 years since
the fall
the city is a corpse and we are the
worms
we burrow in it
fighting for every useful piece of land
to preserve ourselves from the terrors
of the night and the horrors of the day
you can hear my voice but shall
therefore speak a word or two here
anyone who dares to steal food will be
hanged and their bodies will be exposed
every day the guys from dust to choose
between bad and worse
[Music]
these choices we take to survive will
create the world to come
in her literal get to the nearest safe
house and wait until dawn good night and
good luck
please welcome narrative designer Chris
a below
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Chris Avila and I'm excited to be
working with tech LAN to create the
world of dying light - dying light - is
everything you'd expect from a bold
sequel of the first game a fluid parkour
system with improved natural movement
deep and tactical first-person melee
combat and of course terrifying Knights
when the infected emerge from the depths
the city to feed on anyone they can find
at the same time we invite you to a new
vision of the post apocalypse a bleak
and unforgiving reality that we call the
modern Dark Ages today however we want
to give you a look at one of the
impressive new features of dying light -
a technical and narrative advancement
for the franchise dying light - will be
the first at it genre where your choices
have genuine consequences in the game
itself from how it looks how it plays to
the events that occur everything in the
game world can change based on your
decisions the following demo throws a
bit more light on this
[Applause]
sighing light to feature the functioning
ecosystem that reacts on multiple levels
the things you do and the choices you
make in the example we are about to show
you our protagonist undertakes admission
for the peacekeepers one of the many
factions active in the city they wanted
to negotiate with two survivors who are
controlling and hoarding a water supply
final offer
let's say you choose to carry out the
peacekeepers order one way or another
[Applause]
after this you will start seeing a
significant change in the city as access
to the water supply allowed the
peacekeepers to bring stability and
develop the area
there's even running water for the
people at street level and that raises
their morale and allows you to replenish
your energy on the go but there's a
cause to this the PKS have a rigid
approach to law and order so while the
streets may be safer it's only safer for
those who side with them so if you get
on their bad side
now let's return to that moment of
choice and instead of killing them you
choose to team up with this group to
supply water on the black market as you
will see this creates a very different
set of consequences for the city with
water being a precious currency it
brings you access to new resources and
trade but this in turn attracts the
worst type of people to the area
[Music]
and this is just a single decision one
out of hundreds you will have to make
but it allows you to carve out your own
world each player's game experience will
be unique and by the way this is just
what happens in the day at night
well things till they get a lot darker
[Applause]
excluse